can you give a brief history of SpaceX
Rockets so we got Falcon 1 Falcon 9.
there's different versions of those
Falcon heavy and Starship and also the
the Dragon castles and so on well uh
yeah Falcon one is where it all started
the original intent and the original
idea of of SpaceX was Elon wanted to try
to get something to Mars you know um he
saw that NASA didn't have a current Mars
plan
and he wanted to go to Mars so he
decided how do I best do this
um he literally wanted to at first
purchase a rocket from from Russia uh
then on the after a foiled attempt at
doing that he decided he was going to
try to develop his own rocket and the
Falcon one is what came out of that
process and he developed a pretty
incredible team like I don't know how
exactly he stumbled upon the team that
he stumbled upon that quickly but the
people that he assembled were amazing
and they built the Falcon one which was
a single Merlin engine followed by an
upper stage engine called the Kestrel
engine
um pretty small compared to the things
they're working on today but that Merlin
engine continued to evolve uh into being
the power plant for the Falcon 9. they
went from a small lift launch vehicle up
into the medium-class launch vehicle so
they could provide services for NASA
um that's one of the big things they
first kind of hung their hat up was they
got the opportunity to fly cargo to the
International Space Station under um
originally it's called the cots program
the commercial orbital transportation
services uh for NASA which evolved into
the commercial resupply contracts and
that's when SpaceX developed both their
Dragon capsule which is a uh uncrewed at
first uh spacecraft that conducted the
ISS and the Falcon 9 rocket that can
take it to the International Space
Station the dragon rides on is the thing
up top that rides on the big booster
thing that's uh that launches it into
orbit exactly yep the Falcon 9's the the
semi truck the dragon capsules the
payload you know it's the thing being
dropped off basically at assassination
in this case the destination is the
International Space Station
um and uh yeah so they developed those
relatively quickly and uh became a
commercial success before you know it
they're now the number one launch
provider in the world launching more
mass to pay to orbit than anybody else
launching more frequently than
um countries like the entire country of
China who's going crazy right now with
launches granted China beat them by two
launches this last in 2022 but
prior uh prior year SpaceX beat the
entire country of China I mean it's it's
nuts and just like you said SpaceX still
beats China even this year in terms of
the amount of payload that was though so
yeah the master orbit right that uh
China had like 60 something a couple
more uh launches but the there was just
like small cubes that type of launches
exactly some of them are literally like
100 kilograms or something you know like
not not large payloads Bissell SpaceX
customers are different different so
whoever wants to send payloads up into
space yes but right now their biggest
customers actually themselves with
starlink with darling one of the biggest
reasons they've launched so much mass to
orbits because starlink has designed
around the payload Fairing and the
payload capabilities of the Falcon 9
rocket so you know because they're
vertically integrated because they build
their own satellites because they're
building their own rocket they can
literally design a system that's you
know another manufacturer might have
made a more Square satellite that was
heavier or something but SpaceX looked
at it from a blank slate and said here's
our constraints our payload Mass
constraints are volume constraints and
they made a funky looking satellite
things like the size of a you know it's
like a table folded up which isn't
anything I've you know really ever seen
before so but it's purpose built to fit
as efficiently as possible inside their
Fairing and inside the capabilities of
that rocket so therefore
because they're launching those like an
insane amount you know a dozen you know
40 50 times a year or whatever
um they're uh they're just putting up
insane amounts of mass like we've never
seen before what about the different
versions of Falcon 9 so we can Linger on
them what are some interesting memories
to you of the different developments in
Falcon 9. the very first Falcon 9s had a
square uh array of engines it had like a
three by three by three grid of their
Merlin one engines the 1DS and um I
think it only lasted I don't remember it
was two or four flights before they went
into this octave configuration where um
there's eight like a ring of eight
engines with a center engine in the
middle
um still in the same diameter that the
rocket was the fuselage was more or less
the same 3.7 meter wide diameter but the
the actual thrust structure changed and
one of the big efficiency gains was you
no longer have you know a corner engine
and then like a edge engine and then
another Corner engine you can just make
eight of the same you know kind of part
of the octa-web it's called uh you know
the same shape and then the your
interchangeability and your
manufacturability becomes a lot simpler
so that was kind of one of the bigger
upgrades at first and they kept
stretching it every time they like
touched this thing it got longer and
like or taller and taller technically
um and then the next big feature that
you saw uh in 2014 would have been they
added Landing legs to a Falcon 9 rocket
which was I was at that was the first
launch I ever went to was actually to
see
um it was crs3 so commercial resupply
mission three and it was probably there
God I don't remember what that was like
their 14th or 15th launch or something
like pretty early on
um and people were literally laughing at
the idea of them putting Landing legs on
it they just thought it was stupid
they're like why are they wasting why is
this billionaire Elon Musk guy wasting
his time trying to
land a rocket it's not going to work so
you said the Mars planet was there in
the beginning uh what about the
reusability of rockets
was that there in the beginning I think
reusability definitely you know it's
it's a necessary part of making any kind
of interplanetary
Mission you know in order to actually do
that just financially you have to start
reusing these things in terms of the
development of the Falcon 1 and falcon
9.
how early on did the uh goal of reusing
the rocket having the rocket actually
land how early did that goal creep in I
I can't speak for Elon and SpaceX but it
was pretty and you know immediate they
wanted to try to recover and as a matter
of fact I think the very first two
Falcon 9 rockets and Falcon one I think
they even wanted to try to recover uh
using parachutes to recover the first
stage
um and it now fast forward you know
almost 20 years later and Rocket lab is
actually doing a concept like that where
they're uh pulling a parachute after the
first stage is re-entrying and they
actually are trying to recover it with a
helicopter is going to try to snatch it
out of the air they've actually done it
they've actually done it successfully
once how does the helicopter grab the
the rocket with this giant like drag
line and a hook oh I know literally just
like grabs snags onto the parachute
wow and it's pretty amazing and but this
is a small rocket their Rocket's only
about a metric ton that the booster is
empty so the rocket releases parachutes
yep like really high up I'd love to see
this yeah that's an interesting idea
there's so many interesting ideas and
possibilities like SpaceX basically just
innovated
a lot of different weird ideas just in
in the pursuit of making things more
efficient reusable
um all of that so basically thinking
from first principles how to solve this
problem and so what you find is like
you'll get all these kind of crazy kind
of solutions and with SpaceX they
weren't even getting to the point of the
booster surviving re-entry long enough
to be able to pull the parachutes yeah
you know they're Mass fractions you know
and in that varies
every single Rocket's different you know
all the you know for instance rocket lab
uses carbon composite fuselage and tanks
um or you know same thing and that's
very very lightweight has really good
Mass fractions and therefore they're
drag coefficients and things like that
they were able to survive re-entry of
the first stage which is something that
SpaceX wasn't able to do at the time
um what's what the kind of the big I
think breakthrough for SpaceX with
reusing the booster is they uh they
realized we have to basically slow down
before we hit the atmosphere so they
actually do what they used to call a
re-entry burn which I still think is the
correct term because it is re-entering
the atmosphere but now they call it the
entry burn and they light up three of
the nine Merlin engines uh not only to
slow it down but actually even while
those engines are firing it creates like
a a literal like force field as it's
falling through the through the
atmosphere interesting and uh but it
also decreases the velocity by almost
half or around half and then that
therefore decreases the amount of you
know the biggest thing with the
atmosphere is that as it gets compressed
against the front of any anything flying
through the atmosphere the compressed
atoms just get hot and they can get so
hot they turn into a plasma and they get
so hot they can just absolutely destroy
anything so they slow down enough that
the air molecules don't end up you know
destroying the vehicle on re-entry and
then they then they realize I think at
some point there's probably a similar
crossover they're like well if we're
lighting the engines already to slow
down in the atmosphere we can just use
that same engine to land and so like
well what if we just stuck Landing legs
on it and just landed the thing
vertically and next thing you know is
December 21st 2015 they did exactly that
for the first time so you were there
before that then right yeah yeah from
2014 yep early 2014. so that and for me
like that was so fun watching you know
that was like the peak of me just
becoming obsessed with uh with this idea
I'm watching with like and back in the
day it was like months between launches
you know so a launch was like a big idea
I'd wake up at 3am to watch this Landing
attempt or whatever you know and every
you know there's crs4
um almost almost landed crs5 almost
landed crs6 crs7 blew up I was watching
that on I think it was like a Saturday
morning or maybe a Sunday morning and I
remember watching that and watched it
blow up and I was like oh my God now
what you know and it blew up on Ascent
it was their first failure
um so it was their 18th flight I believe
crs7 the upper stage um had a uh one of
the butler's bottles inside the tanks
that are filled with helium and one of
those bottles broke off on ascent and
actually just completely over pressured
the upper stage in the upper stage blew
up and the whole rocket went kaboom in
an uncontrolled manner
and so uh so then they came back with
vengeance when they came back the first
mission back is the first time that they
landed a rocket which was awesome so
they returned to flight after the
anomaly was was uh yeah was was Landing
a rocket and stuck The Landing yep well
actually the first time so the first
time you were there what was that like
what do you remember from that from that
day just I was surprised at how much
bigger the rocket was than I imagined I
was I originally when I was going down
to Kennedy Space Center I was
disappointed that I wasn't seeing like a
you know I didn't know a ton about
Rockets I knew enough to like know what
a space shuttle was what like the Saturn
V was you know but that was probably
about the end of my knowledge I just
remember being disappointed that I
wasn't seeing a big quote unquote NASA
rocket flying you know I was thinking in
my head like oh I'm gonna see this
launch it's probably gonna be like you
know three stories tall or something you
know just some little skinny little
stick and
some little firecracker and yay you know
and I think I'd almost been pitched that
too I think the the people that I was
working for at the time I think they
kind of were downplaying it it's like
well it's not a big Rockets here it's
not gonna be that exciting you know but
we get out there to the pet and I'm like
this thing's huge this is not a small
rocket like this is It's you know it's
70 meters tall 220 feet tall it's huge
um and I think people forget like the
scale of that you know it might look
skinny and tall and all this stuff but
it's still a very very large piece of
Machinery it's physically about as as
large as you can ship the boosters about
as big as you can ship across the
country period without like completely
shutting down highways you know it is
made within those exact specifications
of of like having you know Lane
Privileges and bridges and everything
it's you know 12 feet wide 3.7 meters
wide and it's 45 meters long so it's
like exactly what you can fit uh with a
pretty standard you know like before you
start getting into crazy amounts of
problems shipping the rocket and it's
huge it's huge and people just don't
understand that and so when I saw it
with my own eyes I remember just being
like this is so much cooler than I
thought it was it hard to believe that
that thing is gonna have to lift off the
ground and launch up into the air maybe
that's the most humbling aspect of it
that's something that size humans have
come up with a way to take something
that size and launching launch it up
into the air yeah there's certainly a
very humbling aspect when you watch it
actually leave was was there a sound to
it was there like a feel what are the
different experiences do you first
remember well ironically I didn't end up
getting to see that one fly oh I went
home my camera saw it I left my camera
out there like a remote triggered camera
uh my first image is as a launch
photographer at the time was it was crs3
but I went home it scrubbed too many
times now this is back in the day they
were scrubbing like often and there'd be
like a three day five day seven day you
just never knew so I go home and I watch
the live stream of it so I didn't even
get an experience my first launch and
any anyone that's ever tried to you know
go to a launch is can probably empathize
because yeah scrubs are very common in
the space flight world so that one I
didn't get to see uh but since then
obviously I've been able to
um attend very many launches uh how much
do you understand the control involved
in the landing how difficult is that
problem I couldn't tell you a single
thing about like the code and like the
avionics behind it but I can tell you
all the hardware that makes it happen if
that helps well that yeah I mean to me
it seems like whenever I talk to people
they say it's not
that big of a deal in terms of the the
level of intelligence and the control
but to me it's just like when you
observe it
it seems incredible because of all the
variables evolved all the uncertainties
involved all the
um because there's aerodynamics I mean
like there's different temperatures
there's so so much going on with the
fuel the burning of the the combustion
just everything that's going on to be
able to do perform control at such high
stakes effectively like you know that
code is probably not written in
JavaScript I guess is what I'm saying
actually no I don't it if I remember I
again this is well outside of my domain
um but
um they're coded in a Common Language
it's it's probably it's probably going
to be c yeah yeah I'm pretty sure it is
and that was one of the things that was
weird is that Elon when he you know
started SpaceX like we're just going to
code in the most common language so that
we don't have to like have people learn
this archaic you know weird thing we can
just literally pull people off the
streets and be like here write it you
know and that's probably C plus plus I
mean it'd be epic if it was like python
or something but I don't I I think like
reliable systems have to be written in
CC plus plus probably which is a common
language which is something uh I imagine
like NASA Engineers will probably have
to use some kind of proprietary language
in the in the olden days for for
security for privacy all that kind of
stuff oh and the old and old old days
like yeah they're inventing Yeah the
code and language from scratch
uh for sure it was still it's just still
incredible that it's able to do that
like you just the feet of engineering
involved is just it's truly
it's like one of the Marvels to observe
about these Rockets coming back to Earth
uh that they're able to land like the
drama of it is just incredible to see
yeah well the one of the fun things to
remember too with specifically with the
Falcon 9 and the Falcon 9 or Falcon
heavy boosters I mean it's the same
thing basically
um they shut down all but one of the
nine engines and even with that one
engine at its minimum throttle setting
it's still too much thrust to hover
so as this Rocket's coming down
if they start a little bit too early if
they light that engine too early it will
actually stop above the ground and will
not be able to lower itself it will
literally stop like say and say stop 200
feet above the ground
their only option is to kill the engine
and then it's just going to fall those
200 feet so they it's what we call like
a suicide burner a hover slam kind of
interchangeable terms because your
thrust to weight ratio is never below
one so they have to actually literally
be riding the throttle so what you do is
you kind of start ideally you know you
kind of start like in the middle of your
window of of throttle range so let's
pretend your engine can throttle down to
40 of its maximum rated thrust you might
start at like 70 percent of thrust in
the middle of that like window of where
it could burn it so that so if all of a
sudden it's kind of coming in too hot
you have room to throttle up if you're
coming into you're actually you know a
little too early you throttle it down
you have a little bit of wiggle room
it's just amazing how smoothly and how
perfectly they're able to still control
that thing even though they're down to
one engine out of the nine and they're
still riding like the finest margin of
what's possible and they're continually
playing with that to try to get it
because every every bit of fuel they're
using and proponent they're using to
land is proponent they weren't using to
put something into space yeah so they
want that to be as efficient as possible
they're really like watching them hone
that in and and just continue to evolve
it and edit that and just get it to be
the Workhorse we're coming about 100
consecutive Landings perfect Landings
100 I think they've done like 150
something Landings altogether 160
altogether but we're talking like in a
row without blowing up which you know
five years ago was completely
experimental and insane and now we're
coming up to the point where we're 100
in a row it's like this is becoming more
reliable in the landing which is not the
primary Mission this is purely for
spacex's like gain is to recover the
booster it has nothing to do with the
effect of getting the payload on orbit
you know most of the time and the
landing is really only for their their
benefit and their gain long-term gain
like it's a long-term investment in in
being able to recover the the boosters
100 can you believe all this was done in
basically 10 years so that we've seen
this development over a period of 10
years oh man so like where we started uh
commercial space flight
at scale to today where it's almost uh
almost starting to be mundane yeah how
can I be able to do yeah uh I I can't
really believe it I mean obviously even
just in the I I think I'm a fairly fair
weather fan really didn't start paying
attention to like 2014. yeah and just
seeing what it was like back then to
what it's like like I don't watch every
launch at all anymore like I'll catch
the big ones yeah I'll stream some of
the really big ones but like back in the
day I like I said would wake up in the
middle of the night to catch these
streams or you know catch these launches
and watch them because they were such a
big deal and there's maybe only five of
them a year you know and so it's a
really big deal nowadays it's like oh
yeah there's literally like too a week
on average now it's insane from SpaceX
alone
let alone you know United launch
Alliance rocket lab any of the Chinese
missions you know I mean all of there's
countless it's insane it's hard to
really really really hard to keep up
with I wonder at which point in the
future the number of uh launches to
orbit will exceed the number of launches
of airplanes
like on the surface of Earth yeah I have
to admit I kind of have a hard time
extrapolating out that far you know
there's a lot of people that are like
big futurists and really do think about
like interplanetary stuff and think
about colonizing Mars and stuff I have a
hard time predicting like when
starship's Gonna Fly the orbital launch
you know and that's like imminentish
like month or two scale time frame and
yet I'm still like I can't tell you when
that's gonna I can't tell you anything
about like when we're gonna land on Mars
or what that's what that economy and
what that you know the scale of launch
operations is going to look like in
order to do that because it's just so
hard to I wouldn't have predicted where
we're at today five years ago you know
it's it's insane it's so hard to predict
and
yeah but it's it's funny because there's
so many like new companies starting up
trying to predict that and it's a really
exciting you know startup culture right
I think uh when you make certain
engineering decisions
and hiring decisions and like what you
focus on in terms of both business and
Engineering it's good to think on the
scale of 10 20 50 100 years that's one
of the things that Elon has
exceptionally good at which is asking uh
the question okay this might seem
impossible right now but what's the
obvious way to do this if we look out 20
years and then you start to make
decisions you start to make decisions
about robotics about bringing computer
interfaces about space travel that are
they make a lot of sense when you look
at the scale of 10 20 50 100 years and
don't make any sense if you if you look
at the scale of of just months so but of
course the actual work of day-to-day is
focused on the next few months because
there's deadlines there's missions they
have to accomplish anyway we uh
returning back to the brief history
Rockets
the Falcon heavy so what what else is
there so we talked about Falcon 9 and
the the rapid development there what
other flavors of of Falcon is there and
how does that take us to Starship yeah
realistically the Falcon 9 evolved more
or less kind of like just got more
powerful in a little bit longer and more
capable
but nowadays they fly what's called a
block five even though it's like the
eighth or ninth iteration of the of the
Falcon now but they call it block five
it's the one that has the black Landing
legs the black inner stage they have a
fleet of roughly 10 or so that are doing
the majority of the legwork these days
and they're flying you know up to 15
times I think right now is the current
booster leader they're also recovering
the fairings to the nose cone of the
Rockets are frequently if not every time
being recovered
um same with yeah same with the booster
for the most part and the only thing
being expended is the upper stage and
that's kind of where the Falcon 9 is
ending it's really doesn't make
sense to develop that infrastructure any
longer so they went with the next step
which is go even bigger physically so
they have more margin for upper stage
reusability and that's what we see with
Starship and super heavy so the super
heavy booster uh the whole system is
confusing the whole system is kind of
considered Starship but it technically
the Starship is just the upper stage
which is also like the spaceship which
is also the upper stage and then the
booster itself is considered the super
heavy booster and that's what they've
been working on uh publicly it came out
in 2016 as the at the time it was the
its the inter planetary transportation
system uh later in I think about 20 by
the end of that year 2017 it kind of
became known as the bfr the big Falcon
rocket I guess yeah
um and then I think it was about end of
2018 they started calling it Starship
but that is the that is where we're at
today and that's what their uh working
full steam ahead on and uh what about
Dragon who mentioned Dragon uh crew
Dragon cargo Dragon yeah so they went
from the cargo version of dragon that
flew about 20 times uh successfully to
the International Space Station uh
except for that one crs7 where the
rocket blew up in the capsule obviously
didn't make it to the ISS
um then they went into the dragon true
Dragon 2 which has two variants it has a
crew variant so we just call it crew
dragon and then there's the cargo
version of of dragon two
um and that's just an updated sleeker
sexier version of dragon and it's
ironically it's heavier altogether so it
uh you'll never see those those cool
return to launch site Landing the
boosters coming back to land for CRS
missions anymore like we used to but
they landed on the Drone ship anyway and
um and yeah that's been flying
successfully that's kind of the so
there's the starlink dragon Falcon 9
Falcon heavy and Starship system it's
kind of the whole
the whole SpaceX world really in terms
of the the spaceships involved so what
what do you are some of the major
milestones in that history we kind of
mentioned
a few yeah like in the landing is there
something that kind of stands out yeah I
would say definitely
um the big ones obviously like any of
the first like the first flight of
Falcon one first flight of Falcon 9
first time they went to the
International Space Station
um the first time they landed a booster
um the first time they reused a booster
which is I think about six months after
no oh it was a year after it was SCS 10
um
2017 it was the first time they they
reused one of those boosters you know
and that was a big milestone like can we
even yeah we recovered one we we caught
one you know it's like we got one now
what
um that was the first time they re-flew
one
um yeah then flying humans was a huge
one dm2 Bob and Doug
um for NASA
that was incredible you know that was
that was a huge huge step I think for
SpaceX was flying people so it's this
first major commercial
launching of humans out into space yeah
and not just into space because you know
there's been people that have done you
know space flights with you know like
sub-orbital hops but going into orbit
and especially docking and rendezvous
with the International Space Station is
a it's a big deal it's a whole it until
you really understand the physics
involved in the scale involved with like
just crossing the karma line going
straight up versus going into orbit like
they're just completely different things
almost what about uh Starship are we oh
are we in a place where we can talk
about Milestones with Starship has there
been or is it just been an Epic Journey
of failure and successes of testing and
and so on was there like even like yeah
what would you classify at this point as
uh as a milestone a Starship or bfr
whatever the name is I was able to
achieve well so far the Milestones we've
seen I'd say the first one would be the
Hop of they call it star Hopper and it's
basically a very rudimentary rocket but
it was the first time they they utilized
their new Raptor engine to produce
thrusted to fly something
I first flew like literally like three
meters off the ground or something like
Tethered to the ground then it flew like
15 and then finally it flew 150 meters
and that was in 2019 and that was the
first big milestone of Starship and then
after that we saw
sn5 sn6 kind of do the similar like 150
meter hops with a little bit more
elegant systems you know proving out
more of their their tank building
proving out more of their you know a lot
of just subsystems and then the big ones
physically were in uh end end end of
2020 and early 2021 when they flew the
uh sn8 9 10 11 and 15. what does the n
stand for in SN I think just serial
number
yeah I said these are just names numbers
numerical representations of the
different testing efforts they skipped
some numbers right yeah if they if they
scratch a test yeah and a lot of times
it'd be like literally they're building
you know because at Starbase and it what
SpaceX is working on like the one foot
is always in front of someone else's
foot and like the arm is not knowing
what the leg is doing sometimes yeah
they they will have someone working on
you know they'll just be like hurry up
and build 40 of these tank sections and
you build the bulkhead and you build the
downcomer and you build the header tank
blah blah and also like oh we actually
evolved that we don't use that header
tank now so it's going to go on to this
one so they'll have like parts of
certain Rockets built and it's like ask
literally scrap it like not scrap it
like in the you know joke term but like
literally just go scrap it and they uh
so yeah they just evolve and iterate so
quickly there was some epic explosions
um I think Starship something about it
uh probably just the amount of fuel just
leads to some epic epic failures oh yeah
would you say Starship is the source of
the most epic failures in terms of size
of explosion so you can literally
measure in like a yield of explosive
power you know like like you could TNT
like you can take a look at uh how much
repellent is left over at the at the
time of the explosion and you know
Starship what's flown so far even though
it's physically one of the largest
flying objects ever uh just with the
upper stage alone they've not filled it
more than like 10 or 20 percent full of
propellant yeah and so it actually
hasn't been the the failures have been
really epic looking uh big visual
Fireballs but in terms of space flight
they're still pretty small explosions
believe it or not they could still go
bigger yo yeah a lot a lot and of course
the test payload of a Tesla Roadster was
launched um I forget what year that was
yeah that's 2018. that was quite epic
would you put that on a milestone oh
yeah yeah Falcon heavy demo was like
definitely a a big big big milestone
yeah is that funny to you that there's a
roadster floating out there yeah we know
the location of that Roaster at this
point oh yeah where is roadster.com yeah
oh yeah where's is it orbiting something
yeah it's orbiting the Sun it's orbiting
the Sun and its orbit is basically
between the Earth's orbit and Beyond
Mars so I think of like 2.5 Au if I
remember right so it's it's beyond Mars
orbit at its highest point and it's back
at Earth kind of in its lowest point I
wonder if there's a mission where you're
going to somehow connect with it once
again and like Place extra things into
it I wonder how challenging that is
technically oh yeah it could it could
absolutely be done
um you know the hard thing at this point
because it's on an eccentric orbit would
be rendezvousing with it because you
kind of have to be in alignment with its
orbit to really line up well with it
yeah um but yeah I mean someday I don't
see any reason why we couldn't at least
send for sure and uncrewed you know if
Elon wanted to just fly a a robot out
there to check up on it and photograph
it or something like we could that could
be well within the realm of things and
get an uh Optimus uh robot up there
uh so that was the story uh brilliantly
told by you of the Rockets uh for SpaceX
what about through the lens of engines
can you give a brief history of the
SpaceX rocket engines that were uh used
that we haven't covered so you mentioned
All-Star with the Merlin engine and a
custom engine what um yeah through that
lens yeah what's there the engines are
relatively small number which is which
is easy for us there's the other Merlin
and Merlin's evolved throughout time to
be from like the Merlin to the Merlin
one seed and Merlin 1D to the Merlin 1D
full thrust and all these other kind of
tweaks of the same architecture uh
Kestrel ended with Falcon one
um they also have the Merlin vacuum
engine which is the upper stage engine
for Falcon 9. same relative uh system
but just optimized for vacuum so it has
a much larger Bell nozzle there's the
Draco thrusters which you know you kind
of can consider engines well they are
rocket engines but they're just small
they're not like the orbital engines
there's these super Draco engines which
are the abort thrusters on on crew
Dragon capsule and then nowadays they
have the Raptor engine and the Raptor
vacuum variant but they've already had
two versions of raptor we've already
seen kind of the Raptor development
engine
um we've kind of seemed like a raptor
1.5 whereas kind of taking hints of the
future Raptor but now we're well within
the well within what you'd consider a
Raptor 2 variant
and that's really it yeah for the uh the
Raptor maybe I'll ask you that
separately but I like in general and
people
who doesn't know whoever the astronaut
is but if you don't somehow know go go
go check his your YouTube channel out
you're an incredible educator about the
super technical and uh the more sort of
even the the philosophical the actual
like the the actual space travel so you
go down to the raw details of it and
there's just great videos on the Raptor
engine
um
I think you have one on Merlin uh and
and also actual tours with Elon where he
discusses some of those things on one of
the tours he says uh he's full of good
lines that guy uh he says something
about uh the number of fiddly bits
and he's uh the number of fiddly bits
was decreased between Raptor two and
Raptor one yeah and I I think that's
actually a really beautiful
representation of um the engineering
efforts there which is constantly trying
to simplify oh yeah increase the
efficiency of the engines but also
uh simplify the design so you can
manufacture it and in general
simplification leads to better
performance and testing you know and
everything so the number of fiddly bits
I'm sure there's a Wikipedia page on
that now as an index is actually a
really good one well and when you think
about it I I don't know of any other
company prior that had kind of try to
measure their performance of their
engine not and like thrust to weight
ratio or like how efficient it is like
in specific impulse but literally in
like dollar to thrust ratio like how
much does this engine cost yeah how much
thrust can it produce and like using
that as a trade study instead of just
like pure metrics of you know because at
the end of the day like okay if it's if
it's cheaper and does you know x amount
of work even if it's less efficient it
can actually be better long term and so
I guess another way it's not even just
thrust I don't know if that metric is
used but basically the cost of getting
one kilogram
of thing up into space yeah that's
basically what they're trying to
minimize especially yeah exactly at the
end of the day that is definitely the
ultimate metric is how much does one
kilogram cost to orbit eventually you
know and but there's it's so funny
because space flight is just the
ultimate you know it's the ultimate
compromise every little thing any
variable can just change everything else
so you can tweak so many different
things to get to different numbers and
conclusions you know but even things
like on your first stage when you're
when you're the Rocket's pointing
straight up and the engines are pointing
straight down you're dealing more with
the thrust to weight ratio of the rocket
so how much thrust is it producing
versus how much is gravity pulling down
on it is actually a more important
metric than how raw efficient the engine
is so it's funny then in space it's kind
of the opposite thrust to weight ratio
doesn't really matter
uh what really matters is the actual the
specific impulses color like the the
nozzle escape velocity of the or the
injection velocity of the how fast is
the gas moving is like the more
important number on orbit but it's it's
just so crazy because there's all these
like I would just love to see
the trade studies you know when you're
like trying to figure out like is this
more important than this or this or this
and it's like you change this one little
thing all of a sudden you know like all
the everything changes it's just even
the profile like the launch profile the
trajectory of it the I mean everything
everything I wonder what that trade out
discussions are like because you can't
really perfectly plan everything so and
you always have to have some
spare leeway on on you know especially
as you're testing new vehicles like
Starship yeah so margins are important
yeah having having a margin giving all
the uncertainty that's there that's
really interesting like how they do
those kinds of trade-offs because
they're also rapidly designing and
redesigning and re-engineering
and uh the ultimately you want to give
yourself the freedom to constantly
innovate but then through the process of
testing
you solidify the thing that can be
relied upon especially if it's a crude
Mission yeah that how to do that in a
rapid cycle I I remember at some point
that NASA as they're leading up to
Flying humans for the first time for
NASA
um you know there's some talk that like
we're gonna do a design freeze because
SpaceX does evolve and iterate so
quickly you know they were saying that
it was leading because especially at the
time it was a mission called emo six and
they lost a rocket they've only lost two
rockets like ever really as far as um
you know trying to get something to
space for the Falcon 9 sorry
um and the second one ammo six I mean
that was back in 2016 so it's it's been
a long time and uh but at the time you
know they're looking at flying humans in
the near future
and it's like if you guys keep tweaking
this thing every time you take it out to
the pad really's gonna be a problem you
know and so there is some pressure
from NASA to kind of slow down on that
iterative process and uh but that is
also why they were able to evolve the
Falcon 9 to be what it is today is
because they did just evolve it so
quickly literally like one after another
was never really the same and we're
definitely seeing that with Starship now
like it's
evolves so quickly that you just can't
even keep up with it you know